this episode brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block now you know what
it is imagine say a thumb say if you're
trapped in a wishing well you know but
you but there's no wishes in it because
something happened though with the way
it was built and they had asked best us
and they couldn't put any wishes in
there and and and you can have one
person throw something down that wishing
well and you can catch it in your mouth
guess what that's gonna be
I'll tell you what it's gonna be gray
black pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los
Angeles on the way to the beach gray
block and get that hitter I wanna let
you guys know that I will be coming June
15th and 16th to Yuk Yuk's in Calgary
Alberta Canada June 23rd temblor Brewing
Company Bakersfield they added an extra
show June 29th Paramount Theater Stark
County Wyoming Illinois and July 6th
through 8th levity live in Oxnard
California July 20th through 22nd
charlie good nights Raleigh North
Carolina and and other dates will
they're all on the website theof on comm
slash tour I want to tell you about a
new company called Specter Specter a
binary options trading platform that
takes the middle man out of trading ok
it's all crypto based so transactions
happen on the blockchain man where you
at I'm on the blockchain I meaning there
is no broker that could potentially
interfere or rip you off or mess things
up or wear a pesky suit that you don't
like in bad Cologne those days are over
try the demo today at the link below and
in the episode notes
it comes with sixty thousand dollars in
crypto currency for you to play with you
want to trade US dollars for Japanese
yen click the spektr link if you want to
trade British pounds for euros click the
spektr link if you want to trade kryptos
or just learn about crypto currency or
about trading in general you can click
the Specter link try the demo at the
Specter link below and in the episode
notes and within minutes you will feel
like a Wall Street trader
with all the tools that the big dogs you
once you get the hang of it
sign up for a verified account and start
making real trades with real money sorry
America real trades are for outside the
United States only and they will check
where you are from ok so click the
spektr link get involved it know what's
going on crypto is the is that is the
new tang ok get up on the blockchain
I'll see you baby girls on the
blockchain so try the demo play with the
simulated 60-thousand see if you have
what it takes at the spektr link below
and in the episode notes do you have a
cold sore or do you have herpes hurts
herpes herpes
sorry sounds like a Greek god doesn't
eat Greek god of people's crotches
herpes is a I don't want to say it's the
funnest disease you can have but it's
definitely kind of a partygoers you know
you know it's like body pimples kind of
but anyhow you can mousse your now if
you do have herpes you can use your
mobile device to get a prescription
medication right now that's right go to
her polar comm wo wo alert calm h ER p
al eat rt.com you complete a
questionnaire upload a few JPEGs and
make a one-time payment a doctor will
review your case a real doctor not some
you know not some freak or pervo a real
doctor will review your case in a
prescription will be transmitted to your
pharmacy they had to use the word
transom some transmit it here whatever
anyhow usually within just 60 minutes so
look if you have herpes herpes then 60
minutes or now you cannot you can have a
prescription on your way and be ready to
get in healed
time is of the essence so get diagnosis
and treatment of your cold sores or
herpes right now ww are polar calm
private convenient fast secure her polar
t' and now let's get to our episode
today i got a manís in here here
some of you or listeners who have been
here since day one will recognize this
song this thing I'll make you want to
play your little leg boy
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you hear that you hear this one huh yeah
[Music]
nasha nasha nasha fantasy baby
[Music]
it's never too late to come over
time slips away
[Music]
alright alright alright alright alright
guys that song is uh it was given to us
in the beginning of this podcast used by
a man a magical element of the universe
I mean just like I mean in a special
type of human almost like a you know a
you know as if like that as if you know
they had some Dark Arts but the lower
gift wrapped them you know it's almost
like the devil and the Lord just cleared
their throat at the same time and just
spit something right here in our studio
and this beautiful creature is here
today and that is mr. Stevie starlight
[Music]
awesome man Stevie starlight bud good to
have you man thank you yeah nice to see
today do you thanks so much for coming
in and joining us we just kind of like I
don't want to say we pirated your song
it's good I kind of wanted to move that
close to you so once I donate it to you
guys and dedicated as a gift for what
you do for all your fans you know right
on man well we yeah I mean we definitely
love it like I feel like well why don't
you tell me like how did this song come
about for you well you know I just kind
of just came to me I don't I don't mean
just like shortchange like that just
really came in the matter of five
minutes Wow
and usually my best songs come that way
yeah yeah like the ones that worked on
for awhile we were like alright they
don't really feel that you know yeah but
do you think it is about that you know
why it's just a gift from God when it
comes like that man yeah the music gods
when they give it to you like that you
just got to take it and just run with it
do you find that there's a certain time
of the day or year or anything like that
and there's a water for you right there
if you want it do you find it there's a
certain time a day or year that you feel
those like compulsions or those you know
what there's no time and no no no exact
time because it comes at random hours
it'll be 4:00 in the morning I'm sitting
in bed I'm like I hear a little
something in my head I go I gotta get up
and go put that down because if I don't
it just goes into the ether gone and
then I'm like damn what kind of that
what could that have been you know you
know and when I went to force myself to
do it and sometimes is this forcing
yourself to do it cuz it's like you
gotta work it yeah and you do it and
then it's like wow I'm really glad I did
that yeah for that particular song
emerges it Nam it happened like oh my
god this that's a little riff and then
the lyrics just came out a man could be
higher than a mountain I just really
just came out you know when I wrote it
all down on paper within 30 minutes and
a song was gone
yeah it's a hit man and so whenever like
how did you get into the tunes man how'd
you get into tune I'm a stepdad played a
lot of music growing up you know 12 13 I
was breaking the strings he'd be coming
in whoopin me yeah was he a decent man
he was you know what I didn't understand
time it was very strict very disciplined
disciplined you know to the max you know
yeah Gary
Wow yeah whatta Mallen and that didn't
like yeah yeah Mahlon yeah that's a
fruit - if you have a list yeah look
watermelon right so I yeah you know it
was like he was very musical though so
I'm very thankful for that
you know he had keyboards all around I
was always just trying to pick up what I
could you know so that's really how you
got into in a music yet is basically
because of a step because - you said
that had these elements around totally
very much so you know he was there and I
lock him up in a room and I'd sneak
sneak out and I go into the room and I'd
have to lock that door up you know but I
eventually figured out a little trick I
put a belt on a coat hanger uh-huh yeah
and it latched under the law under the
underneath the door and get it just
right where do I hear it and I pull it
down and the door would lock and I'd be
out the other side Wow figured out my
trick later on you know you wonder what
movies like that's pretty smart that you
figured that out so he had to respect it
a little kinder you know with music like
what's your journey been like with music
like did you start here in Los Angeles
did you come here to Los Angeles like my
real dad was like a playboy he was out
here working for Orion Pictures doing
the whole thing you know a single
bachelor man mm-hmm
and and I came out here on the on the
Christmas vacations in summer and and
I'd love the air out here I felt
something was different about this place
you know I don't want to be out here and
he's like hey what should stepdad doing
is he's still whooping y'all come there
with him like you feel like that he
actually flew to text one time he was
pulling your ear you gonna step outside
Steve and all here is like a cartoon
he walked out guys come on let's go to
the park Steve
I realize it's Italian great crazy dude
man so you had the Italians in the
Guatemalan
wow man your mom likes to [ __ ] a broad
huh and they're both have like the same
birthday November yeah both hardcore
Scorpios dad crazy right so what does
that tell you about your mom like when
you look at her partner's like what is
that it was a crazy fire - she's an
Aries and she's just like I don't that's
fire but she's very uh she's like her
mom a lot she's Aries same same kind of
vibe I feel like yeah like you know it's
a certain certain energy you know but
then
to be left alone but they also want to
do a lot on their own there they got a
young mind but they're also very very
smart about things to say it's
interesting but I love my mom I talked
to her you know yeah I don't call her
all the time but I wish I would yeah
call anybody all the time I finally I
spend a lot of time on myself
huh solitude and we so when you got out
here um so your your father your real
father was living out here yeah so you
came to visit him I did and then at what
point did you kind of make that move
that full move out when I was 17 I got
kicked out of my place in Texas
something you had to come out here so my
deck was all right you come with me and
I spend a week on my dad's couch he
booted me kicked me out there too for
what cuz I rode my bike and I snuck out
of the house and he's like you want to
go out with them you want to go outside
go out with them now I needed like took
my bike rides downstairs because now you
go with them well I had nowhere to go
and I was like calling her dad please
come home and we can do it nobody's like
a week later he's like I come home Steve
well we can make you stay out ya know
week I was out there bro I was running
with these freaks belly dancers in
Venice going nuts on rooftops I'm like I
love this people playing bongos awesome
well but like two days later you start
getting hungry yeah tonight that roof is
kind of getting a little weird you know
yeah so they knew something you had to
get back home yeah you know and then
when did the so so now you had these
musical elements you're living with your
dad out here and then what happens you
know I just I felt like this is what I
want to really do I gonna put my best
foot forward and really just stay on the
grind and just like you know take it
seriously and did that happen or did it
not happen
well I've been I took it seriously I've
got my music in a lot of movies and
stuff and I've I've made money on my
music I still do that's why how I made
my money mm-hmm as I support myself and
um so I buckled down somewhat to to at
least get that into a position where I
can you know sustain some life energy
out of it yeah and whenever like so but
taking it so when did Stevie starlight
start that happened when I had it my
real that last name is Natali's
you know like my dad says his last name
was Christmas they call me Stevie
Christmas but that's in the past uh my
grandfather's name was Nick so he was
Saint Nick natales uh-huh Christmas
so uh yes so basically uh
I was in this band called the Stevie
Natali's band when all that Iraq war was
going on and people thought about Stevie
in the Taliban and that had to change
real quick so my drummer I broke down on
my car this 57 mercedes-benz right and
I'm driving my car had no headlights no
dome lights no rear lights no brake
lights no nothing
I loved and went out that's the dark
arts I'm like I'm gonna make it home
it's got Jimi's beautiful guys still
talk to him stay long hair Italian dude
well glassblower has a shop on the
street
I uh he goes to make at home he's like -
do you like Stevie starlight and he put
that name on me - created a monster and
I turn the homeless TVs to highlight
dismay at the time cuz he didn't really
like that but he sports whatever I do
he's a good guy so so at that point so
Stevie starlight was born born that day
that night and did you take it on as
like an e like a persona or was it just
a stage thing you know what it's a good
question I um I took it on because uh I
I felt I can do more and not step out of
my box because you have some of the name
knows yeah to run with he or someone new
yeah and now I'm getting to a point
where like I wonder maybe trends
transmogrifying to another element you
know like maybe just might who I really
am Steven it's Hallie huh
you know so you mean my back out of the
starlight I might be a little you know
little to tutti-frutti for some people
know I didn't see you okay I never would
are you wearing a beautiful there
weekend yeah so I want to know like like
with music because now was it a did you
feel cuz a lot of people move to Los
Angeles and music is like their dream
right our music is they had this goal
that they have to achieve and if they
don't get there and you know and they
really equate a lot of who they are - I
think levels of success how is that
honestly looked for you like in your
life well you know what this is a good
question - I think about that a lot but
I don't I'm out I'm not too hard on
myself I don't be myself up on it
because I know I have a certain path and
that's ultimately gonna take place and
whatever happens in
time is good and this is the way that
God wants me to do this I'm gonna do it
yeah and I don't beat myself up too much
good for you man that's a night that's a
nice gift to have it's not myself up I
do though sometimes cuz you know I can
be my own worst critic as well and I
might not crack that whip like
underneath the 5 on myself because I'll
be up at 5 in the morning making music
and I'll still do it right but um I hate
some times I wish I did have that a
little bit more that others had that
gives me more in tune yeah a little bit
sometimes yeah it's a give-and-take you
know right it is a give-and-take it's
such a give-and-take man cuz it's like
you know we're just talking a little bit
ago about having to do you know
podcasting it kind of takes away from
being able to do stand-up comedy
sometimes it's like it's uh you know it
it's still awesome and it's still a neat
thing to do and it's like a fun way to
communicate with people but you know
it'll come like you know I'll have some
sets in the evening and then I'll be
finally be sitting down at like you know
8:30 to start thinking about jokes and
ironing that out and so it's it's really
tough and it's tough when you're a
creative type of person which I'm not
ordaining myself a creative type of
person but I mean I couldn't run a
[ __ ] you know like there's a million
things I couldn't do but I can sit I can
sit in a chair and think up ideas good
yeah but when you're a creative type of
person it's tough to have that other
side you know it's a your own boss yeah
it's like I'm my own boss and I'm also
the worst employee you know a killer out
on some stuff you know Chris definitely
helps out I mean I have a big help from
Chris and Nick that helps a lot next
nice yeah cool guy yeah he's a suit he's
a super guy he's a premature baby but
he's um yeah he was it couldn't tell oh
yeah if you get to normal it already
comes it's about a month shock funny but
he's like an eighth month you know it's
like a month old forever but he
beautiful young man yeah
but yeah so how so were there parts so
you didn't really attach your you didn't
attach kind of like material success or
Hollywood success you're happy no no
basically I knew I was gonna make it so
it didn't matter right and maybe that's
gonna be when I'm 50 but I know that
it's all you go what you go through the
journey like I slipped the script on
that one when I said enjoy the
destination
we're already there I mean you're
already there enjoy now right you know
enjoy the destination because you know
they enjoy the journey you do dude this
is the journey and the destinies you're
already here right you're already at
your destination it's right now it's
right now you know it's just like an
idiot it's almost like a just a way of
reframing the way there isn't breathe it
was wake up and be thankful for your
breath and just whatever happens
throughout the day you know you'd be
happy for it yeah you know you're alive
you know that's great and it's amazing
to stay in that place of gratitude
yeah you know I'm thinking as you say
like you know the journey and the
destination I'll I'll start to realize a
little bit like as you know as little
things will happen as I go along in life
maybe I'll you know get to work onstage
with somebody that I really admire or
like somebody that was like a a hero of
mine growing up as a comedian I'll hear
them at like a show of mine maybe in the
back and all of a distinct laughs yeah
this is like four years ago they had
this guy named Damon Wayans who used to
be on in living color yeah I'm very
familiar with him yeah and he I heard
him in the back he was in the back of
one at a show I was at he was performing
next but I heard him laugh Wow because
he has a very distinct laugh I was like
wow that's crazy long as they're
thinking hear that and it's the only
laugh I get here I just suddenly just
from wrong out it's like got like a
little Christmas veil and then so you
have little moments that kind of like
exact you know blue fire a few months
yeah you know that's sustained yeah yeah
you're on your own again man you gotta
figure this out and but then you're back
to just yeah you're back on your own but
I'm starting to realize that it's the
parts in between those where you're
battling it out or you were staying with
the bad and that's a lot of that those
are really the funnest parts those
aren't really the most it's the
challenge it is it's the challenge for
sure
yes it's the joy it is that journey that
is the that's the that's where you learn
about yourself yeah I don't really learn
about yourself in the moments that are
like oh when you're on stage playing
that's not what you learn about yourself
you don't learn when you're talking so
much you know you're learning when
you're listening you know yeah I so
those moments when you're looking for
things and you're listening you're
peeping out things you're like trying to
attain some inspiration yeah that's when
you're learning
yeah yeah it's so funny I don't even
know what I'm saying I know I'll believe
you though it's like say you're driving
somewhere like you but you don't learn
when you're on stage when you're playing
the music as much yeah you learn when
you're off stage and then it comes out I
go into another element sometimes when I
don't even know I'm there and I'll just
transcend into a thing or I could just
feel free and I'm not even trying to do
that that's not what I'm like sometimes
I'll be very focused and understand
what's going on at the moment but when I
find like I'm going to a solar so I just
let loose you know
and I don't I can't couldn't even tell
you what I'm thinking man man I really
couldn't say no they put my stuff on to
a brainwaves and asked what are you
thinking right now I don't know what
they were finding that thing really and
so if you do your whole time here and
I'll have you lived in Venice if you
live going all round man through a girl
rock East LA down to Malibu I've been in
Venice most of the time yeah Santa
Monica of course um Venice has changed
huh big-time big-time what's happening a
ministry well you know just saw I'm
looking at this nice painting here at
Venice I know the guy that actually
painted the whole of that building right
there behind that Mercedes the hole all
that stuff is an amazing mural artist oh
yeah is that with that oh that's what
the bar is right there
Danny's mm-hmm across the street is
Larry he's been in Venice has changed a
lot of the good people are still there
all the OGS are there all the Venice
crew is there that I know yeah I still
go back there all the time and say
what's up yeah a lot of good people
they'll be still there I love them yeah
but um as far as the dynamic of all the
you know stores moving in there and you
think it's that and all that stuff
people got a little perturbed with that
I guess they think they bailed out of
their Google was their snapshot Vice
bunch of stuff over there they just feel
you know Peter on because that's just
you know it's a really hardcore town
Venice yeah yeah well I'm fascinated by
it because I just know it from like an
outsider's perspective Mariah so but
yeah I mean it has this it has this it's
like we're the we're salt water kind of
met grunge a little bit or met I don't
know you tell me about oh I got my foot
wasn't like and what is it like I was
five years old my dad was living out
there and then I went down at the beach
I felt something in the air
and ever since then it that's that
feeling has never left me it's always
the same when I go back there if I go
that today I'll feel that same feeling
when I was five
you just talked about to see of the day
smells and certain things could bring
you back to something yeah
and man just right right when I go there
I feel it and I'm sure people do
wherever they're from they can go back
to that place and feel that feeling it's
really beautiful but um Venice is a
special place
yeah it'll always be and times will
change people come and go but that
energy will always be there yeah I think
do you feel like I mean I mean you know
a lot of times I noticed that things get
changed by you know when money moves in
you know when money moves in or when
things become it's crazy it's like when
we start to put I don't know if it's
appreciation on something or value on
something or when something is cool it's
hard to keep it cool yeah yeah you know
talking about things moving in like that
and I did some reading on some things
that's actually like a good thing
because you know young money comes in
and old money moves out it's just like
it's a way of recycling things you know
and that's that needs to happen actually
in life that's it's gonna happen no
matter what they care about it anyways
but some people get a little you know
attached they feel like it's their home
or whatever but you know what I said
sometimes that's the way it is man it
has to happen that way that's
interesting yeah it's like a lot of that
maybe then is just about attachment it's
like we get attached to you know to the
way a street was yeah to a family that
you know or to what the what we like to
see when we look outdoors we like to see
that and then we get attached to it when
that changes that kind of scares us yeah
for sure it's interesting how you know
Venice is such a it's such a I don't
want to say it's like a there's it's
almost like this bottleneck of like art
and dreams and yes in Isis uses people
out there they've living on the beach
you know yes out there on those little
bungalows or not bugs but uh those
things cabana cabana type things that
are called all along the beach um
are they campers no that I campers are
just like this little um but day you
know no koto Degas yes something like
that I don't know yeah lose my mind her
begonias her flowers let go to you know
talk about pedo bday Goethe you know
like those things were they all hang out
under and this is a little about a
gamate yeah yeah yeah you're all still
there man they're just drinking the day
and then just like getting by but I'm
like wow where do you who do you want to
do you know is what you wanted to do me
but this is what they want to do yeah
this is what they're into what's a lot
like do you feel like so a place like
Venice like in in like you you know you
say it's still the same some you know
but other people have moved in and
things have to change and that's the way
it goes so do you feel like that a lot
of people we want to be so free but then
yet we get so attached yeah they want to
be free but some people were born there
you know some of those people that were
born there those are the ones I'm
talking about have a real like
connection with it and then kind of like
mad people are stepping in there yeah
they kind of need to get over that in a
way because they're always gonna be
there nobody's gonna tell them to leave
there's like it's like no one's gonna
tell them to leave but um people always
want to come to Venice like it's it's
like millions of people every year come
there yeah more you know it's pretty
fascinating it is it's a nice place
though it's gave me a lot of inspiration
helped me write a lot of song as I spent
a lot of time there my life and
hopefully all spent a lot more time
there too
yeah you have any children or no no then
yet how many a shooting star no children
yet man it could happen one day we'll
see you know I've been saving some a
little bit of semen at the house bro
yeah yeah frozen yet yeah my buddy said
you can just freeze it yourself oh yeah
yeah why not make so much of it I might
as well put some away right spraying
it's like I'm just yeah I'm burning this
dick at both ends I might save a batch
or two you know
mm-hmm so we wanted to have you come on
man I mean we appreciate you letting us
use your song yeah memos for you guys
and it's fun man I type that in like
hope you like it man coming back boom
this is a banger I can't wait to put it
on um I saw things feel yeah
it's just so good it's such a uplifting
hit and we would like to do an album
comprised like different you know maybe
different songs over about after another
year yeah and then put them out
you got my blessing appreciate that and
we'll do um you know we'll probably do
like a profit share where have the
profits go to the artisan half of me
will find a charity or something we'll
think of something cool yeah whatever
you guys want man I'm with you guys all
the way I love your attitude though of
just you not holding too tightly on the
stuff mmm
you know what I've another side of me
too like I need work help and work on
right there's things that I get you know
hyper sensitive on I need I need work on
as well yeah I'm in no way by a perfect
person but I do appreciate you saying
that you know I do try to be as positive
as possible yeah yeah this tough it's
tough these days because you do want to
you know and I find it even in here
working on the podcast like how you you
know we have such a good game playing
and we have a good goal and then
sometimes but then and there's certainly
edgy and feisty moments along the way
yeah and I watched all your stuff too
man
oh yeah it was my fan before we even got
in contact and I was watching you know I
showed Britney a bunch of stuff she's
hilarious
oh thanks dude you know and I mean said
why is this guy global and I'm like - he
is global - everybody every world knows
about this guy today Marie you're a
little down yourself for not being
accepted into the Jimmy Fallon thing and
it's you know how that whole thing's
changed man I'm watching people that are
on there right now yeah I almost throw
up dude
so I'm so sorry - because you were so
deserving of that thanks man yeah a lot
of me off some stuff has just gotten so
boring yeah and they say some people say
they're so accepting but it's only
accepting in a weird way and that's what
politics involved I don't know if we
should go into that right now but yeah
we don't have to but it's very I know
what it is though man I know what it is
it's really weird I think just a lot of
people are disconnected I think there's
just some different perspectives you
know when people aren't seeing the same
world true you know people are just
seeing the different worlds so outside
of music like what other loves have you
had in your life man um you know what I
love a lot of things I like just a lot
of artistry stuff you know I thought act
lately I've been doing getting some
let's get some stuff you know yeah
commercials and stuff that's cool I
could see that man you definitely seem
like kind of like a UH a bit of a
flamingo
it's something I wanted to do but kind
of got pushed into it like helping this
one person then from there I got a
commercial agent so then from there I
did like three commercial Oh like I
don't even really know what I'm doing
I'm just having fun with it ya know it's
being in the moment trying to trying to
figure it out
what are things you do to stay in the
moment you know that seems to be like
kind of a theme why would I have severe
attention deficit hyperactive disorder
today I am in high definition dude so
I'm trying to get a spork yeah just to
be here and just to kind of um being in
the moment with you yeah but I uh man
all the time the day flies by deer so
fast my mind is races and races and
ringing I gotta take a few stuffs
meditation helps a little bit yeah I'm
not that good at it I just try just
breathe and just like relax giant helps
you know just kind of like what you eat
and what not what times you eat but I
have severe ATD I came to read a whole
paragraph or something and forgot to
forget what I just read sometimes very
frustrating sometimes okay so when you
get to that point of like like what do
you think happens because I noticed this
too I'll be reading a paragraph and then
halfway through I'll start thinking
about something else you might have a
little bit of it but I won't even notice
where I left yeah what the the story I
was reading I won't even notice where I
left that and went into my own is your
where that's going on in my head I might
have some of it and it's nothing that
it's not a bad thing it's an artist
thing yeah
very creative thing should embrace it
what do you think it is why do you think
it happens like I know that you know
there's all these scientific reasons but
like what do you think is going on that
we would just drift off because you know
we're reading something yeah
and we said exactly we had intention to
read it yeah of course you want to read
it it's basically it's chemicals in your
brain do that or not that are not
formulating too so you can attain focus
is the problem and you have so much
going on your mind maybe that's not as
important to you is what you're trying
to think about right now do you think
it's any of its ego like we think that
what we're gonna create in our head is
than what is already here oddly I don't
think it's like that it's in the moment
like more than a moment it's just like a
matter of what you're doing in the
moment like you its chemical in the
brain there's all I know what that's
what they've been telling me all my
chemicals in the brain a little brain
telling us I don't even know what it
means but like I told me he's I'm trying
to pass along yeah I have no idea but
you know I've recently all the time I
don't remember what the [ __ ] I just read
you I don't know what I just read and if
I don't feel dumb because I know like
I'm a smart person but I I'll go back
and read it again I'll get it yeah woody
do you notice that the has gotten better
or worse over time and not even having
to do with with the with attention
deficit issues but with just the way
that we've evolved as people and how you
see just in your own life do you see any
do you see that it's harder I don't see
I don't know if the the problem has
gotten worse or better but I know that
I've gotten better as a person I'm Ralph
because I've been you know I've learned
more I'm more advanced with my way of
thinking so that helps it right so you
got right okay so you you are now yeah
you're able to like at least regroup and
you know read it over again or
re-examine it or take a moment in them
we approach it yes before I was
frustrated and I would understand you
know but now that I've matured I
understand what's going on here and I
think that my level of comprehension has
gotten better yeah do you think said but
say it like you were to read a book when
you were 20 and you read a book when
you're 40 you're like one is easier than
the other for me forty is much harder
right to read a book you know forty yet
are you no but I'm 38 but so you're
right I'm born in 1980 both of us oh
really both monkeys okay go oh my god
yeah both from the south
yeah from Houston are you really is born
Wow yeah I made my way up to New Orleans
a couple times oh that's good what took
you there just partying people on like
little little party buses and whatnot
we're going into New Orleans for the
weekend you want to come sure I'm
fourteen I'll go have a party whoo yeah
yeah yeah I was out there as a wireless
time never had my life right down there
too
oh yeah yeah you know yeah there's some
real s Fiasco country yeah and some real
fiesta yeah you see beads out there all
year long yeah
oh yeah one lady um one time had a bunch
of beads in her [ __ ] oh my god yeah wow
that was like why was she just Fanning
in my Ottawa yeah she just pulled him
out for it and nobody wanted yeah that's
too much it's like yeah lady oh my god
one of them uh-huh
yeah she thought you were one of them
and they look like they've been in there
a while room you know like definitely
nobody wanted those last week either of
those God with a girl in there I mean
something happened to him I think they
got in a little bit you know yeah they
might have been pearlized a little bit I
know but then somebody armor we had a
girl tried to put a piece of sand in her
vagina and tried to make a pearl over
like about 11 years how crazy today huh
yeah damn kind of cool it's really they
got some real adventure bears down there
yeah yeah um well since we loved your
song so much we wanted to have you come
in and we want to we've had out so many
songs submitted over over the past year
I mean wow honored that you guys play me
and after having almost submission yeah
no we look very cool of you guys stood
it's an uplifter and we'll play it more
often sometimes we go through cycles
where we you know get stuck in in one I
watch oh I see all the other stuff is
really good to me oh thanks names Jacobs
and uh yeah all of them everything you
put on his grave yeah well thanks
stealing good company yeah well I think
you are thank you yeah I think you are
man I think you're the leader of good
come all right come on we want to roast
a couple of songs out here you can like
him and I can roast them we've already
asked people if we could roast their
music people have sent in some great
stuff over the past year and people are
sending some I'm up for whatever people
send in some real [ __ ] oh come on let's
do this and I have personally emailed
these people you have and made sure I
said look that's good they probably feel
good about that we may roast some of it
so Wow
all right so the first one we're gonna
get to is kill my buzz by Jimmy de Moura
and this is actually the one that even
started this because this guy
specifically asked us to roast them Wow
kill my buzz and whose buzz a
grandparent yeah well we're gonna find
out it's like maybe talk about Buzz
Aldrin do it's my thing
and I looked Buzz Aldrin in the eyes and
it look like he hadn't been to space and
all
and I remember that episode you said
that I go wow that's interesting because
I have my own thoughts about that whole
thing we'll get into that wind okay
we're getting that right after this hits
not too bad not too bad I'm not throwing
jabbing if I feel it man but it's
actually bad yet I see this one being
like a beach okay mixing a little bit
that hip-hop with that artist I mean
with that guitar music yeah pretty good
okay let's phase out of that one man
yeah I feel I guess something you listen
to maybe at the beach you have fun with
your friends you know or if somebody um
like if you like threw a frisbee into a
neighbor's yard you go yeah turn it back
up again Zach what's going on yeah yeah
you go then get it that's that's our
plan yeah like oh [ __ ] prisons ever
better running to get it precisely
[Music]
okay cool that's good what do you think
about that moon landing man you
mentioned that you know I had my
thoughts on and off about it and I got
wanting off too I was very big in you
like I don't hate space and star wars
knowledge I'm not into like Star Trek
let's get that one thing clear
really star light don't like Star Trek I
don't just seemed a little like yeah not
beneath me but I just never got it right
as far as like the alien stuff and I was
way to that for a while like I had a
vision of this alien like hovering over
me I don't know if I was abducted or
what I think I was abducted there's a
strong vision of this reptilian was
there and it was it's green and I still
see it right now I'm ahead it's really
weird so that was like and that came to
you where was that at in Texas no I was
out here yeah yeah and I was in my bed
now as I was had these pair of
paralyzing moments we couldn't move and
you think things were going on to you
and I roll with that for a while because
the more you think about that the more
it's gonna progress then I had an entity
that was like a spirit that followed me
around and I was through a couple
girlfriends that lived man I mean they
finally left anyway to invited the
girlfriends no but they would they would
leave and would come on way heavy into
Munich and it was scared you're asleep
so would asleep yeah I wouldn't sleep
that's so scared I was you know went to
sleep of course there was again waiting
for me dude so it was waiting on the
other side of sleep yeah I was waiting
right after you exactly oh my god it was
so scary so but anyways as far as the
space and that's gone now that left me
about 10 years ago like a shadow kind of
that's right with the song Shadow Man
subconscious really yeah creeping
darkness shadow on the wall
I felt the footstep monster me it made
me crawl and I mean living lonely the
secret world of mine I'll wake you up in
the morning and lead you on the starting
lines and so that was that was one of my
songs Shadow Man so I'm gonna put that
out a little bit later yeah let us know
man well yeah space stuff though I
really was fascinating fascinated with
it for some reason something and it
still into this day but you know I have
my thoughts with the moon landing I
think it did happen because and I think
it didn't happen the Van Van Allen belts
and all that stuff radiation how the
hell you're gonna get past that why
don't we not go back and that's all the
sudden Russia say hey you guys really
didn't go
there or like why don't you know China
there's so many reasons that why I think
that they didn't go there's so many few
reasons why I think they did go to you
know they they just didn't have that I
need to go back the space race was over
with as far as Russia and right what are
your thoughts on that well it's like did
we get there and then there's no more
value in going right like because it
seems like nowadays with so many
companies that some company almost would
be like we want to get there and put an
advert you know like I've heard that we
were banished from the movie that we
went there and we're not supposed to go
back really yeah by someone or something
some things that are up there and we
were banished but now why wouldn't Neil
Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin and those guys
if they really went why wouldn't he well
you know on his deathbed Aldrin not buzz
I was the first kind of Armstrong's from
the first kind of name you know that he
sent his kind of convoluted message did
you ever hear that case you should go on
on YouTube after this and just check it
out his message to humanity really yeah
you gotta hear he says basically seeing
the whole thing was a hoax
uh-uh yeah and then he died a couple
days later but I wonder how do they know
okay we're gonna get these men who were
going to carry this lie forever
yeah they're gonna be actors almost
right yeah but not only they have to be
actors but they have to I you would have
to want to act at a level that was so in
your core you never wanted to be able to
deceive it xi know that they were gonna
be able to keep it deceptive all right
Buzz Aldrin got put on he punched some
dude in the face did you see that video
no I'm not surprised though every day I
look at me he looks pissed yeah he's
like you are not an astronaut you did
not go to you did not Paul knocked him
out right the street and he jacked it's
kind of cool well he probably got tired
to hear it from yeah that's what it is
yeah and I think that if we can fake a
moon landing we can probably trick a
couple people to make them think they
went to the moon so horribly think that
they did if the moon landings faked they
probably just thought they were that's a
good point maybe they did go somewhere
yeah you know it could have been since
oh yeah it could have been dad they
never even been to North Dakota they
probably could have been there right I
heard that Stanley Kubrick directed the
whole thing in here in Hollywood oh if
you see these little X
different little parts where they're
getting the printouts for that you know
it's kind of very convoluted I notice
Joe Rogan was way into it yeah and now
he's like doesn't talk about it you know
I don't want to get sweet of that but
like I don't know if they got handles no
look it's fascinating it is but also as
we become more technologically advanced
especially in cinematography and
everything you start to see how easy it
would be to do that yeah I heard the
technology in the iPhone is more
advanced than was in the whole Apollo
spaceship when we went there on the
blows Alou yeah yeah that's a yeah a
tumble I mean it's like say if one day
robots take over right I wonder if
they're going to be mad that we owned an
iPhone or if they'll even know though
because like this is that's a certain do
they really know all the stuff that we
know as far as feeling and like having a
empathy that they don't have that robot
robots wouldn't have that I don't think
but I wonder like you know you know like
say if they had a manifest now of people
that owned slave and their own slaves
you know roan you know throughout time
yeah okay and if they went back and
looked at people's names and stuff they
would get pit people now with people
being robbery would be upset at people
that owned the slaves right okay they
would say your your lineage yeah of
slave ownership okay so I'm wondering
that same thing if one day if robots
take over told to be mad at that no if
robots take over will they look back at
us and be like oh you used to own one of
us ah I don't think so because they
don't have that that that's that one
feeling that they won't ever have that's
what humans have they're a robot that
they can't ever have that feeling
feeling of deserting empathy or or or
they're not it didn't even know about
tricking they don't even know about
deception I don't even say they're just
they're just one focused beings that are
right there to do a job that's why they
cannot be manipulated and otherwise
thinking you know but do you think if
they could say there are some that have
become awake okay if we want to use that
try to kind of describe that right is
that be an extra chip you gotta put into
those okay but or but say if somehow
they there have some that have become
awake awake
they the smartest thing for them to do
would be to not let us know that yeah of
that smart that's an advanced level of
robot you know think about robots now
they're just like in Boston groups are
started and moving then you see him now
that I go should have started do some
other [ __ ] now yeah but those was one
the other part of its a whole crazy
thing yeah there was one of a robot
there's like a robot that but they
caught a robot blow and I do know yeah
outside of vana and he made the robot do
that or the robot just willingly robot
showed up at his house [ __ ] blew him
and they called the cops crazy that's
crazy you want them out of there
immediately with you down you're done
man the whole weekend you know doing a
lingering robot so yeah there's stuff
going on out there but I'm like the
smartest thing for a robot to do would
say if I'm a robot right I'm a robot
okay and I'm supposed to do like
whatever missions I do every day I wake
up and I do my missions right whatever
I'm supposed to do whatever my own or
whatever my master tells me to do but
then one day something like turns in me
and I start to get an idea that I'm a
robot right right but I realized where
other robots are right now that they're
all still not awake so I need to just
continue to do what my master says and
do my job and do my job
until one day there's enough of us awake
where we all yeah I don't think they'll
ever have that in the robots are not
equipped with that because they have
only mechanical functioning you know
they're not like they're not there to
love you and hug you and start feeling
embracing relationships it's very like
mechanical and very linear there's like
right they were they were the smartest
thing for them to do would be to not let
us know for a way yeah I think yeah
until it was time for him yeah that's
what I'm worried about I'm worried about
sometimes I'm late microwave is being
like only do
I think it's all that's what I worry
about sometimes I think that's a good
imagination is this something could have
happened you know let's say let's say
let's check another song Chris here we
go what is this so this next song is
October by life eats life oh right it
sounds dangerous
yeah
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
the log page you have only on the guitar
it's kind of nice and light like it a
little modern rock action okay I'm just
remind me of kind of 1997 turn it up a
little bit
the whisky a go-go 1999 is that what
that is yeah yeah what is this I feel
like they're goats dying in the
background like I feel like that yeah
yeah definitely some warts been going on
a different level I feel like there's
like spousal abuse is gonna eventually
occur not out of the gate at first you
know supportive of your endeavors but
eventually so unsure to the show then
the merger back you never go and watch
out but after about the fourth city you
guys are in White Plains New York it's
gone haywire yeah she's killed a few
ghosts yeah yeah she's the one that has
to go out and find him during the day
you guys in kill him at night they're
just rehearsing you know they're like in
the barn rehearsing where there should
be many go there's no more good honey
yeah a lot of goats and that's when the
fights start huh and they probably use
that in court they play that in court
yeah and they'd get the idea that I
could see that yeah I could see yeah
it's definitely his fault
and that's life eats life yes life eats
life by October October right yeah let's
play one more time this sounds like two
dudes probably blowing each other that
don't want to blow each other like what
are we I don't know what do you know
yeah what are we doing this yes that are
angrily doing it but also work it like
them is the same factory play one more
time yeah right now that it's looking at
each other and putting down their coffee
mugs and their I think they're at the
factory not one of them just like
started blowing the other one and the
other ones like all right I'm ready for
all this
like yes we are and now it's the same
now all the dudes in the factory blowing
each other Oh God
the cheapest store coming out checking
them out Oh doing yeah and they're just
license plates everybody thinking
license plates yeah and they just say
just a bunch of hearts on them everybody
just send a bunch of dudes at a factory
falling in though that's a gay porn that
would probably sell I'm telling you
right there that's true what a director
the gay porn yeah we will have to make
yeah maybe this all goes to porn and
yeah that's right let's fire up another
one Chris all right this next one is
breed before death by gang breed before
death three four it breathe breathe
breathe before death
[Music]
the assets kicking it right now yeah
this feels like that ass this time yeah
just trying to creep up on this year and
then that bus ride going to school
fourth period Miss Alice's class that
disease a monster okay yeah this seems
like somebody's trying to drown but
there's the the puddle is very small
they fell in a puddle and they're trying
to drown but there's not enough water in
it
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
this would be classify a second elegant
thing right this has a little beetle zu
look I do I kind of got a feeling for it
you know you're kind of like there's a
little bit yeah I feel a little bit
whoa now that is really starting to get
to a bad trip for now yeah now you just
stood in front of the mirror yeah I go
well they're looking for you now your
grandmother just called on accident and
you don't know what the [ __ ] that
spawned a whole trip for me one time
when I was on acid my mom called me up
know and I ran on his hot hot day
they're like taking off my clothes I was
like that guy do it wasn't a church I
had always in a chair I had taken seven
hundred hits acid I didn't know of
microdot black pyramid hold on hold on I
thought that it was like it's just
taking one right but it just it's like
this little tab like this like a
triangle and I knew when I bit into it
and I fell all this [ __ ] spew out inside
my mouth oh wait I don't think it's
supposed to be that much guys but within
ten minutes I start stripping cuz
usually got away like an hour he's got a
700 hit something is equivalent to that
someone told me yeah so extra for ten
days but here's how brilliant I was I
went back to school I had to go to
school dude that's a vacation that's not
a church changed my life dude oh yeah
yeah for the better I think because I
had such a beat down from that acid I
mean when I came out of I just had such
an appreciation for the world and for
living dude like what do you mean such a
beatdown
oh I saw so much in just moms in the
woods dude just just agonizing pain we
actually in the woods you got your
apartment no no I was gone did I ran
down the street in The Woodlands Texas
where I'm from that's where you're from
yeah dude the weather's did nobody
Andrew Donnellan used to be an abandoned
really know a lot of bands come out of
there it's crazy they were called up
peligro
no that is called peligro peligro huh
yeah danger I don't remember names of
the band
damn did you ran off into the woods
Hollis I went to this chick manis place
where we'd always go after school cuz
nobody but her parents were never home
the one day I go her mom is in there and
there's 40 kids out there cuz it [ __ ]
broken up a party obviously right guys
I'm like seven-five 30 feet away 30
yards away by a tree and I looked back
and I hear them all looking at there
I hear them all exact or saying they're
all over they're all talking about
running instead of running I'm like
Forrest Gump running her all around the
town so then I ran a nick Stanley's
house right and his brother psychotic
alright he's doing a perfect match she
goes Justine here I'm gonna get back in
here mom has all these uh heads of goats
and horses and moose coming out of the
wall
taxidermy [ __ ] right taxidermy oh my
look at this we're all coming in on it's
the craziest [ __ ] ever so I hate
drinking like 15 of these hi-c fruit
punishment getting water but it's not
good but it made me trip harder but I
didn't know that high sand might have
been six yeah yeah and my tongue was all
red right but I didn't know that I just
break them and ran tits next Damon's
house all I hear is Nick what the [ __ ]
are you roar and I'm like hiding in the
bathroom but I'm like throwing up
because I'm so sick right and then and
then he I can't from the light for an
hour I'm looking for the light switch I
couldn't find the light and we're the
lights on or off and I'm in the dark and
I'm just trying to throw up
I hear Nicky but kicks in the door boom
flips the light on like like it's
nothing lights wrong I still his red
[ __ ] all over the walls
what was it blood I see but I thought it
was blood so he goes like this
yes just what the [ __ ] and I think
something's wrong with me now so I'm
just crying and running from house to
house it was the worst experience of my
life dude I don't even know how we got
into that right now all that band but
dude I'm glad that I actually
experienced that man because if I can
experience that experience anything dude
so with the end of that and I want it
man eh
yeah you seem like definitely kind of a
rowdy houseguest to have around that
time of your life big time but B that's
interesting reminds me whenever I would
do LSD yeah you get the end of the trip
you're kind of glad that it's over
because you've been through a lot
yeah yeah this would never end those 10
days would just torture and I would and
I went back to my house and my own house
man and then like this Pink Floyd post
would be pulsing poof poof I remember
every day starts early be posting a
little less a little less a little less
it wasn't ten days probably five days
but like it seemed like an eternity so
long yeah and you had in you head
and you were and you'd go to sleep in
this wake back up on LSD yes yeah I
wouldn't sleep actually I didn't sleep
like four days because it's so so
tripping yeah it was very crazy man it's
tragic at the time but uh looking back
and it's kind of itchy something the
first night to come back in it's like 9
o'clock I'm trippin hard and then my
moms like look at cuz cuz she set me off
cuz I'm looking at this checkerboard on
the floor and it's like checking all the
chequered speech from black and white
they all became one thing they all just
[ __ ] up my phone ringing like Obama
yeah yeah right so it the phone's
ringing but it's moving like every time
it rang the whole phone's move horse I
gets it our team doesn't really do that
yeah so I wouldn't pick up the phone
hello she goes Steve you sound weird
I go what I just jump through the window
dude was crazy like ran down the street
taking out my clothes I was that guy and
my friends are all running after me stop
stop and they're like hey you gotta eat
this eat this again see that she's like
you're paranoid paranoid later I'm just
be running through everything someone
said to me would fire me off and it
would never end
Navy star like I came back home and my
stepdad Edwin's on the couch watching
this thing about the guy to do something
on acid tuned and I thought they had set
this whole thing up for me I think I'm
sitting he's like yeah he's doing I said
you don't ever want to I said that's a
bad drug Oh Steve I said don't do I said
not even to be telling you that why your
acid yeah yeah I thought it was all set
up hoarse by the acid government yeah
we're gonna get Steven know I can sense
that a hundred percent some reason when
you're on acid it you're able to link
everything there you know everything
allows it all stitched together totally
and it all makes perfect sense sick time
oh man
dude yeah it's that that's why they call
it a trip because it is when you get
through the other side man you decide oh
so glad that's over
yes yeah I can still this day just taste
it and just be thankful that that's over
with man could you ever do acid after
that or no I waited 10 years to do it
and I came out here and I did it tried
and it was great yeah how old are you Oh
15 when that happen
yeah that's maybe 16 do you honestly you
have to be honest with me yeah
do you honestly think that if you you're
the same person if you wouldn't have
done that it would be no way I would
have lived a life of terror in agonizing
pain and not being in touch with myself
because I'm a complicated individual
yeah but I took that it was it was a way
that had to do it cuz I wouldn't have I
wouldn't have found myself dude I would
have been a very awkward I'm still very
awkward but I would have been way out
the gay dude hmm
I would have been living in apartment in
Texas with a chick who's like hates many
cheats on me I mean what do it name
Kristen I like that you had should have
been a [ __ ] yeah I think I would have
had it like go work all day you know
what I mean no but it sucked and I would
had short hair and if it has been it
would not been the life I wanted dude so
thankfully out for all that dude that's
amazing because well here's the
interesting thing is if that had been
something where you that didn't it must
have been the right thing because you're
thankful for that big big time yeah I
went through that I'm happy changed my
molecular structure dude from the core
well yeah and you wouldn't look back on
something if yeah if you weren't
thankful for you'd be like oh well no it
wasn't good for me you know yeah yeah
exactly
it wasn't good for you that you wouldn't
be thankful for it yeah obviously this
the fact you're thankful for it shows
that there's are as it sounds that you
know ending up on the equivalent of 700
it's hits of acid was good for you yeah
big-time
it was what you needed you never would
have thought at the time of this [ __ ] no
no right dude armor one time taking some
and uh our thing was we were like in
student council right so like you know
it's kind of nerd alert sent out but me
and this other dude named Pat were in
there and we took some mushrooms before
the student council meeting one day so
we went into like this meeting before
school and I'll you know these like kids
are in there and stuff and Pat just had
that he was the president right and he
took a marker and got up on the on the
board and he thought it was a dry erase
board it wasn't hmm so he just takes a
marker on a regular chalkboard and he
was the president every day just waiting
to hear what he says yeah and he draws a
line across chalk board he goes this is
right now and then he draws a line like
going straight kind of down a little bit
of a diagonal to the bottom of the board
and he's like and this is where we're
headed if we don't get our [ __ ] together
you fight inside Sarah yeah
meeting adjourned his helmet and I said
of hip hugging class I thought it was
like a real important thing you know and
nobody else class no I get it ha oh no
he drawn a marker on a real chalkboard
that's the facing student like that's
all they saw was like oh I get it though
you explaining oh I get it you know and
so I still have been clapped and then
some of the rest of the day I was on
mushrooms and I had on this green like
felt shirt yeah and I remember in
science class I started just thinking
the moms were snakes right and I got so
like literally for like nine minutes I
was just looking at my phone snake hands
are coming together huh to the point
where finally the teachers like hello
right and she's right here by the side
of my head and like everybody's looking
at me she's like what are you doing what
do you say I said I'm just babysitting
these snakes uh-huh what are you doing
all right it's her problem yeah
and then she's like yeah I think you
need to go to the restroom that's what
she's saying so she might have been used
to use acid and was give me a breath
right then another time we ate some
ended up waffles in this uh they had a
urban gentleman that was our waiter
named big Daniel and that's even what
his tag said on this thing big Daniel
which I don't know you could put big and
front of him on a nametag
it's just Daniel you know bluff you know
yeah and he tried to [ __ ] my buddy one
time whoa
yeah no acid oh wow and I think he I
don't know if he knew we were on acid if
he was like a pedophile or maybe he was
just I don't know maybe just wanted to
[ __ ] somebody and we happen to be there
Wow
you know or but anyway let's listen to
one more let's listen to another was
roast a little more music here all right
so this next one is called shadows that
be by the sway
[Music]
[Applause]
did
[Music]
it's like a little bit of like what do
you what do you think it sounds like I
don't know man it's like got a lot of
elements going on to it yeah yeah chick
singer there it's like no it's cool
a little flute yeah yeah I don't know
[ __ ] it looks like a little bit of
Fleetwood you know mixed with like a
Reba McEntire on there you go McEntire
is a good call
it's got a little bit of Reba in it yeah
it's sweet sound there who was it
that's the sway yeah this way yeah play
a little bit more and bring up the
octave just or the volume ii said one
more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not bad yeah it's good little band their
little claps going on yeah I wouldn't
mind hearing a little more claps a
little more Solon yeah baby I like that
stuff too it's good yes you can almost
use I mean it I'm being really
judgmental oh yeah it's good a destroy
some stronger pipes in there yeah you
know were some backup sisters or
something in there right there rocking
her deep you know don't get discouraged
keep singing it's good stuff yeah it's
tough we like it yeah and we're just
being judgmental because we said we were
going to our job right here all right
let's take up another two in there
Christopher this next one is called jump
by Matt Kiara and this one is just
instrumental okay all right
[Music]
gay bathhouse and there's a shark in the
water yeah bathtub yeah how bad doc I
like it
tell me I dig it yeah yeah it makes me
kind of smile and feel good yeah yeah I
kind of feel like I want to see where
it's going it almost feels like it's
somebody's perspective all right but
there's no vocalist to like you said
that some will be like you're gonna be
waiting for something for a while that's
a smart little trick they're doing there
yeah you know leave you on forever the
fighters we listen to the thing for the
rest of your life yeah this guy likes my
[ __ ] yeah it feels like the background
music in somebody's head if you're like
a really cool person or the matrix or
something like that yeah that sounds
good Chris Thanks that's cool
who was that again that's almost called
jump by Mackay era jump by Matt gear I
like it man yeah let's fire up another
woman what else we get okay so this next
song is called closer to myself by
astraphobia
okay astraphobia that's something again
this is a Stevie star like you haven't
you have astraphobia
[Music]
modern rock is that what that's called
modern rock study stuff
[Music]
it's making me blue it's not my style of
music I don't even off that I'm into it
but I'd sing my lady mrs.
okay yeah I feel like it's just like a
genre of music it's like yeah of modern
rock it doesn't see it doesn't feel like
a you a new sound no not at all
right 1997 yeah whiskey a go go death
metal bands trying to beat core right
but they're conforming to modern rock
yeah you know is that a hard thing with
music that seems like one of the
pitfalls is just falling into playing
what is already there it is if you're
gonna go out there ever thinking you're
gonna do something that's like [ __ ]
like to try to please someone you can't
ever do that you look for the genuine
people that make music that are making
music they make me they're not trying to
fit a mole but and they they're really
making music for themselves doesn't say
that make music for other people that
are lying you want to you want to I read
a great article about David Bowie she
doesn't make music for other people the
good that's good for him and I love
David Bowie but I make music for myself
the [ __ ] that I like hopefully someone
else is gonna like it make sure that you
don't like you don't I mean I can't
stand that yeah that kind of just grinds
my gears when I see that they're trying
to conform to a style and they're only
selling themselves short because people
aren't gonna like it anyways yeah trying
and I'm not trying to boost myself up so
it doesn't sound like it you just
sharing it yeah that's a real truth yeah
you're only gonna get so far that way
room and if people have heard it that
kind of stop stuff and maybe I was
finished certain genre that's been done
that's fine I'm just saying um you can't
go into it thinking that because there's
no way out you get your clothes dry
paper bag or a bag yeah there's no
there's nowhere else to go you know for
you exactly as a person there's other
trails you can follow of other sounds
but there's never gonna be your own path
it's not easy either I'm not saying
that's right formula you know yeah oh I
see what comedy to I mean there were
times not first started out I tell jokes
it sounded kinda like Mitch Hedberg and
then I would do stuff that's and that's
what everybody was doing people were
just obsessed with him at the time and
he had such a Cantonese know what's it
called a candy as a religious behavior
yeah and so people you know would say
yeah I've been watching a lot of him
lately now he's great genius you know
he's not here with us anymore he wasn't
like the play you're funny of the ham
dude well he's I mean he get know that
right it's embodied he gets pushed into
this thing like you got best because
he's dead you know yeah and luckily
you're still alive you got a long way to
go yeah I still have a lot of time to
really [ __ ] it up yeah challenge man
that's true huh yeah
just stayed true to yourself man you're
gonna go as far as you ever wanted to go
yeah I already having a lot of ways man
it's really cool it's been fun man
I've been have this past years really
really been great I think just being
accepted more by some of my peers you
know because for some reason inside of
me you know being I think we all just
want to somehow some type of acceptance
of course it might be for me it might
even just be we want to accept ourselves
yeah that's what um but yeah I think to
live inside your skin I mean it's for
everyone that's gotta be a challenge
yeah yeah it's crazy [ __ ] cages right
totally
some crazy cages Victor Oh what else do
we have Chris all right so for this next
one not only did we get a lot of like
music submissions but you also get
people like writing this theme song Wow
sending this in it's really cool so this
next one I'm not sure who it's by but
they wrote us this theme song to play on
the show okay
[Music]
oh this seems like a rapist in like 1980
I don't think this fits the avant vive
at all dude it's like a rapist in in
8000 safety of on there too isn't it
sounds like kind of a chubby guy who got
like stuck in a big pipe I hear a black
out of glasses looking on some console
he doesn't quite figured out yet yeah
it's like his first attempt ever totally
he's in an elevator making a little bit
of movement that's not really how you do
that who made that Grizz who was it you
know I have to look up the email we can
put it in the description but it's not
attached oh wow awesome and what what
else do we have
okay yeah that seemed like a pervert in
like 85 it seemed like somebody who just
took some out of the box and plugged it
in that's the first thing you did yeah
might be a few backing tracks started
going on there yeah yeah done all right
so this next one is called death creeps
acoustic and also they did not include
anonymous submission that sounds like a
good name for ban and a sex movement
bigger body yeah Anna rattling move you
know totally all of them all that
[Music]
when your thoughts are broken
when you go a little bit of Soundgarden
something that yeah here too hard to
come out of it good
[Music]
very much better Soundgarden a lot a
little bit yeah like art some influence
maker he's definitely called it it seems
like some dude he's trying to be SunGard
yeah trying to be Soundgarden seem like
some got jerking off like it works after
I was that like a candle
yeah all the dogs are asleep yeah this
picture Chris Cornell tape down there
yeah it's some guy just kind of jerking
off and maybe you listening like some
dogs snore in the distance maybe
splatling supposed to be like watching
on my practices yeah a good voice decent
vibe yeah yeah it was a good vibe I'd
watch I'd go watch that guy like evolve
a little bit yeah he what else he did
uh-huh
you know I don't know how to go see him
or buy his album but it's good yeah yeah
I would hope if you were my neighbor
that he would get a little bit better
but it sounds like he seems kind of
possibly a little more than just like
spirits he's dedicated yeah he's good
yeah okay so this next one is actually
my favorite one it's by a rapper named
Jay savage okay and actually played this
one a while but a long time ago in the
show okay so we're just gonna give him
another take okay this is a rap by jay
savage my favorite comedians name is
Theo von I always did laughing whenever
he go on I download then the sewed as
soon as it time is that celebrate living
baby right from the top did a this past
weekend was amazing so why did he have
to love me that he almost ate an Asian
Kiko cadet easy to know he [ __ ] hates
it he always sees a beer on his waitress
you got a problem with his hair you
should save it he knows it sucks he's
just trying to make a statement
he used the jerk himself my mother used
to spank him if brother tried to touch
his dick under a blanket this longer
take your date to miss show he might
dong her but he'll let's call it a nice
dark arts like people call it in this
saying that they eat parts drug-induced
gay sex at a rest stop but they resume
aggressively
just Mardan Theo is a hamster expert a
guinea-pig prodigy he's really smart you
would think he had a law degree
someone she give his ass a PhD in
mockery he talks about a spillage and
that really means a lot to me
plus he's been in bed with [ __ ] Joan
Rivers comin to the stage is a
stone-cold killer so go ahead and drop
his ass a couple billers on patreon
because there ain't nobody really vo
dance it's [ __ ] great right Jason yes
lyrics that really means something and
put her together like that yeah true
events plus he's like dude he's on your
jock like a [ __ ] you love you
yeah he might be also a study could be a
stalker but he's at least a lyrical
stalk you should put that patreon link
that would have been really the extra
mile for you you know I mean that
lyrical stalker yeah it's pretty good
though he's talented I was waiting for
the beat to come in though or like a
little bit of music
yeah no music free flying you know
that's good free flowing yeah I think
it's uh it was nice of him to do that
yeah that was real nice of me yet what
else we got Chris edit okay now we got
one more I thought we'd end on an old
classic this is a submission called
the Latino lawyer by tiny Santa okay
and this actually isn't an old classic
this is a brand-new yeah
this is a brand new song from tiny sand
whoo okay and tiny has submitted music
over over the past year and we don't
even know who he is
really and he's just a man from out
there in the middle of nowhere and he
could you know it's really crazy some
people think he's in India and some
people think he's just in our hearts but
he emails us real songs that he puts
together so let's hear that one
[Music]
at the 62nd delegates are gonna put you
know what I love in San Francisco 1966
I'm here baby
where is Harvey Milk maybe with the FFO
you know where he was he's working a
little too hard on that wah wah pedal he
just take that down just a little bit
yeah the high-pass filtering thing too
nice little lip rip there just a little
licks there something he's in a room far
away that's it but it's good though I
like it
not bad Wow that's it huh that's a tiny
sand - that's a new one from him yeah
yeah and I bet he does get a lot of Wawa
he gets up while going we just chugging
that you know anybody's got a little bit
of that base filter coming he's gonna
while well supposed to because what it
does taste the fruits of some
low-to-high goes well especially a sweep
wash but if you do that fast that's that
sound you're gonna get right I like it a
lot yeah I thought it was cool yeah
that's that soggy sand ooh and that's
the last one we got yeah it's great get
so many great music submissions and you
know from like JP from Alabama we supply
a lot of his songs and Jesse was sorrow
we played a bunch of his songs as well
too so it's kind of cool we have this
like musical yeah I did definitely do
yeah we've had a good vibe of music I'm
an in man in and you certainly have done
that as well I wanna give you one of
these wallets too bro oh wow so pick out
one of these aren't you want this black
one it's going off so pick one that you
want beautiful and that's from one of
our sponsors rig well that's nice dude
so yeah dude it's just a front wallet so
now you would take all your stuff out
and you put it into this of course let's
put it into the front which one do you
think I should get this one of that one
which one you go which one you going
you see what I got I got this got the
black one
this one's kind of grey maybe this is
like a pewter alright with this one yeah
the gold yeah that cool yeah you got it
bro yeah no worries dude and I want to
listen and I want to thank you for
coming and doing our music roast yeah of
course and and I know people can find
your dates or anywhere you're gonna be
forming into your music where well
basically this last two months have been
recording this new album it's going
really well
really according on on tape dude way out
in Riverside Wow
Tellis awesome God has his old board
just loves my music he's not like
charging me just wants to mean we've
been doing it the right way man and it's
gonna be the best thing I've ever
recorded and all the songs and there are
[ __ ] hitters Dan you get them all
dude dude we'd love to at least have one
oh I don't see you guys put on whatever
you want and that'd be awesome but uh
it's the best thing I've ever done and
I've been working on for two and a half
it's almost done and I'm gonna have it
ready for the summer and I got a bunch
of dates coming out I'm not gonna get
this little tour I'm gonna go on but you
guys can catch me at the Viper Room and
stuff I'm gonna have a few few dates
like that coming out in the next month
okay but I will definitely send you that
info yeah let me know if you ever want
to put out if you own one episode if you
put my song in there just you flip that
little vibe on there but I'll have a big
show coming up soon
cool man and so much I think you know
like the spirit of you letting us use
your music you know I think it's just a
good vibe for us to try to keep in here
you know in something we that we want to
try and do well I really appreciate you
guys saying that and you know hires me
to keep going to man
yeah well I think you know even just
seeing you today just kind of reminded
me I think like a lot about you know
like what kind of some of you know what
you know what the pot like what this is
all about you know it's like you know we
want to you know it's so often
especially in this in Hollywood and even
in the world today it's like we want to
keep things to ourself you know we don't
want to really share him as much you
know without some sort of gain or some
sort of you know but that wasn't you
know you didn't say anything like that
you know you were just like sure man you
know if people are gonna love it man
let's love it yeah I'm all about that
dude about the love man yeah cuz people
are like that nowadays snap that breeds
hate there's a lot of haters whether
like haters all these haters I'm like
what's a hater obviously don't know like
too many haters dude yeah laughs they
are they keep it really tight to
themselves they don't let me know it's
good I'd rather have it that way don't
[ __ ] bother me I don't bother with
your hatred yeah dude but yeah the fact
that um that you did that for us you
know I think and that's something I
think a spirit that will try to keep it
alive and you know that Stevie Starr
like Vai beautiful man thank you do you
Batman can you put it on for me right
now bro yeah yeah I just have to listen
to it man yeah there we go
[Music]
[Music]
yeah forever in here
[Music]
the cats love this song yeah Joey Diaz
cats yeah set it free yeah just don't
say goodbye
are you go Stevie yeah baby you and me
enjoy the destination nation nahshon
nahshon for the fantasy painted on the
wall
it's never too late to come over
[Applause]
time slips away from you and me now
sound sound isn't saying they gotta come
over why must we wait we're alive Wow my
baby that's it man take my time chances
come along Valentine nothing could go
wrong our beams shining on the moonlight
moonlight see your dreams I'm an angel
of the night
it's never too late to come over
sound slips some way for you and me now
how yeah nice thinking with you please
don't hesitate to come oh yeah baby
why must we wait when we're alive say
baby that's good man
the mayor drums go away
cancel oh yeah so it's are too bad
we need some [ __ ] cat
[Music]
I wish we have more animals in here
get a few animals in here oh yeah we
don't allow right rhesus snake aside hey
that's it get a breath
[Music]
climbing up the chimney right there oh
yeah
[Music]
it's beautiful man I tell ya I
manifested it's not to sound like I was
a fan but like I am a fan always will be
like I was seen your soul and your
energy man I'm like me and that's not
how I am dude I want to connect with
feel and I kind of like level with him a
little bit I sent you that song and I
was so pleased with your response man I
felt like man there's more people like
like that needs to be out in the world
sharing love doing what you do man I was
just very truly honored so I just want
well no thanks say thank you man
well I think is a blessing and a reason
than why you came you know here today
you know to be with us and because I
think some of that is is just a reminder
you know of what our whole plan is about
here the things that we're trying to do
you know and I think you know can always
use doses of of that yeah you know
because it's easy to you know it's easy
to forget when you start you know when
you're you know in your kitchen or in
your brother's closet and then slowly
just you know things get a little bit
more just bigger yeah you know and not
even much bigger but a little as they
change yeah it's easy to forget where
you know just kind of where it was and
just to remember like what your heart
was thinking then deep breath yeah
thankful yeah love it it's never too
late man it's right baby it's never too
late bro yeah why must we why must we
wait when we're alive baby dude that's
the best line ever TV thank you so much
and thank you all the fans of this past
weekend for a been really supportive and
very cool your comments and sending me
love and liking my stuff I really
appreciate it guys thank you very much
you bet man we'll send a lot more over
and
and thank you Brittany thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
[Music]